to the youngest country in the world
south sudan is marking 10 years of its
independence from sudan
on july 9 2011 south sudan was
established as the 193rd country in the
world
but the birth of a new nation came with
great challenges
and friday's anniversary was a somber
affair people have been told to stay
home due to the corona virus pandemic
one decade ago the people of south sudan
only knew one thing
celebration this was their independence
day
after more than half a century of civil
war with the powerful north
the population of south sudan voted to
secede
by an overwhelming majority 99
were in favor but the birth of the
youngest nation
came with a burden for many generations
this land has seen untold suffering and
death
we have been bombed maimed
enslaved and treated worse than a
refugee in our own country
but
we have to forgive although
we will not forget but just
two years later civil war broke out
again with
ethnic divides fuelling the conflict
president salvakir from the majority
dinkas sacked
vice president rik machar from the newer
peace agreements between the two sides
came and went
almost 400 000 people died
finally in 2018 kia and machar agreeing
to form another unity government
in 2020 they were sworn in as president
and vice president it will be our
responsibility
to restore people's lives
and to inspire them once again to
believe
in the republic of south sudan yet
widespread corruption and violence have
hampered efforts to build a functioning
country
south sudan is poor despite rich natural
resources
one-third of the population is displaced
60 percent are dependent on food aid
rampant inflation and natural
catastrophes make
the situation worse but 10 years on
people are still yearning
we just need to change this leadership
all these leaders our liberators i think
they must
take the backseat and give the country
to the young people
who have the energy and who have the
the aspirations and the hopes for this
country to take lead of this country
after 10 years of independence south
sudan is still very much dependent on
outside help there's little to celebrate
in juba
for mondays i'm now joined by nicholas
haysum he's the head of the united
nations mission to south sudan unmiss
hello sir welcome to dw news africa now
ten years ago
there was great optimism about the
future of south sudan
fast forward to today have those hoops
been fulfilled
no i think quite frankly uh most south
sudanese would accept that their
that their hopes uh of what independence
would bring
have not been achieved um
i think uh the function of this
anniversary is really to remind
people of those ideals and to put back
on the agenda
uh the hopes that they had
for what independence might deliver for
south sudan needs 10 years ago
so have there been any achievements over
the last decade
well i think you know given that south
sudan started as a
uh what should i say a clean slate they
had no institutions very little roads
there has been some progress in standing
up the state
i think most people would say not as
much progress as they would have hoped
for
but they also would have to take on
board that
south sudan has gone through two civil
wars in the 10-year period since
independence
so bearing this in mind what is daily
life
for someone in south sudan well i
think as in much of this area there
would be a difference between someone in
an urban area and somebody in a
rural area the particular concern that
we have as the international community
is the extent of food insecurity across
the country
and the very high percentage of south
sudanese
who face who face not only food
insecurity but the real prospect
of famine and some of the causes of that
are natural
in the sense that there's been flooding
but we're also
just that some of the causes of the
current food insecurity are man-made
people have not been able to plant
because they have
their lives have been disrupted by
conflict
and the planting season has come and
gone
without without people planting yeah now
there's been a so-called
revitalized peace agreement in place for
nearly three years now
is that making any difference i think it
has made a difference
we've seen a reduction in the levels of
violence
at least politically inspired violence
but we've also noted
an increase in what is often called your
intercommunal violence
which has largely taken up the gap uh
intercommunal violence is more a
reflection of intercommunal tensions but
also
the poverty and the economic conditions
in south sudan
very often centered around the theft of
cattle
and the perpetration of revenge
revenge attacks
[Music]
so we are trying to make a difference uh
in that picture with our peacekeepers
but also through engaging elders
and representatives of the communities
in
deliberating and agreeing arrangements
by which
communities can live together uh other
than
in the presence of armed police
so sir you took office a special
representative earlier this year
what's the main change you hope to
achieve for the people of south sudan
during your time
well what we would like to do is to
support the south sudanese
people to make progress
in their transition down the
transitional pathway as it were that
they have agreed to follow
and that involves some quite uh
significant steps they would have to
accomplish including
agreeing on a new constitution that is
the arrangements by which they can live
together in peace
uh making progress in the arrangement of
the first
democratic elections in the country
and more generally in building the
institutions necessary for a state
to be a young democracy
and and and to begin the development
trajectory we would like to see or the
people of
south sudan would like to see nicholas
haysam head of the united nations
mission in the republic of south sudan
thank you